now to present the award for the best
performance by an actress to
distinguished artists ladies and
gentlemen first a Belle who in my book
very few girls hold a candle to his Kim
Novak and of course the gentleman who is
indicative in our business of capital
gains truly a great champ
mr. James Cagney ladies
Namah legs are you Susan Hayworth I want
to live give her a car separate tables
Shirley MacLaine or some came running
nixed Rosalind Russell for Auntie Mame
Miss Elizabeth Taylor a Cat on a Hot Tin
Roof all right
she is the lucky lovely Susan Hayward
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
and thank you ladies and gentlemen of
the Academy for making me so very very
happy tonight and my special thanks to
mr. Walter Ranger who made this possible
I thank
you called the lady for a second just
just one second
I would like to digress if I may or at
least take something upon myself I'm
sure the Academy won't mind I think that
I have been at a few of these
magnificent functions I've never heard
such a rooting interest in my life and
rather than allow miss Hayward to exit
just on the round of applause that she
might assume is just the normal round of
applause I would like to have her come
back and let us all wish you the very
best Susie will you take another bow